[Musik]
ja wir waren erstmals gold platz tragen
fußball spielen was man gar nichts
mitbekommen die rega war dass die
fraktion im vollen gange habe noch
versucht hier die autos wegzufahren aber
wir schauen uns mehr die straßen zum
start werden separat über
straße in wuppertal haben
die sind dann alles rauslassen
ja und haben uns dann auf die garage
hingegen hoch gegeben und haben der
sache freien lauf gelassen
das kann man sich nicht vorstellen da
ist auf der garage gestanden hat das
wasser im hoch konnte man zusehen dann
einsteigen und hier war eine stürmung
könnte man nur von nur einen klick vom
reißenden fluss also fahren weder 50
höhe und wellen
also wird da reingeht zwar keine chance
und als auch hier das auto
vorbeigekommen floss das wasser stand
bis also in die wohnung und wissen meter
in die wirklichkeit
wir sind jetzt gestern abend aber fürs
nach zwei uhr morgens war dies natürlich
67 8 cm schlank gemacht also im herzen
die garagen sicher mehrere die
kellerräume also alles was dort drin war
ist chairman also waschmaschinen
trockner geräte fahrräder alles alles
alles kaputt
[Musik]